[Music]
today's episode of the screen junkie
show is brought to you by M&Ms what's
going on guys
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is hitting
theaters I had the opportunity to sit
down with the cast and take a look into
a mirror universe where the guardians of
the galaxy play the Avengers I know
right check it out
well guardians volume 2 Congrats on
delivering the goods yet en say hell
yeah thank you dude here was a big man
on campus itself Drax
what's like a creepy text message that
Thanos could send you directs what do
you wear michael rooker the whistling
sounds great in the movie yeah are you a
real Whistler yeah I do it I did the
whistling I do all the whistling I want
to put you on the spot can you give us a
little taste oh yeah I could go louder
dude oh I got afraid an arrow is going
to come right no right now
Kurt Russell's such a pleasure to meet
you your performance is so great I was
wondering what would be like to see you
as a different character in the Marvel
Universe I have a couple of lines here
Oh wouldn't mind done these are my
audition yeah it's the Hulk glass Bruce
Banner would you mind giving us a little
bit of that
Oh smash Wow you want me to cold read my
way out of Tony Stark yes sir I can do
that let's go if there's one thing I
proven it's that you can count on me to
pleasure myself language point to me as
if I like cursed or something language
well puny God I could do this all day
that was perfect that was good I felt no
the water one-take wonder yep you didn't
see that coming
that what you nailed that you nailed
that don't make me angry you wouldn't
like me when I'm angry I think you just
stole his part I get sorry mark
dr. strange door mama
I've come to bargain ha ha ha ha
um um I think you'd be a great Santos oh
my god Josh returned to me again empty
handed I will bathe the starways with
your blood
Scarlet Witch you guys know I can move
stuff with my minds right wait you know
what you're doing I'm knocked out Adolf
Hitler over 200 times well it's been
lovely talking to you thank you for the
book and for the horrifying story and
for the threat upon my life wow you're
giving Cumberbatch a run for his money
ha ha ha Jack come back some coming I've
come too far for anything else I am Loki
and you will kneel before me Wow
powerful I don't believe in fairy tales
about chakras or energy or the power of
belief there is no such thing as spirit
that's beautiful Clara I'm going to have
to ask you to exit the donut so I don't
want to join your super-secret boy back
fine I'll do it myself wow you just you
just struck fear throughout the galaxy
let's play the scene Steve Rogers and
Tony Stark back off I'm starting to want
you to make me big man in the suit of
armor take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist you
know you may not be a threat but you
better stop pretending to be a hero
you're a lab rat Rogers everything
special about you came out of a bottle
put on the suit we'll go a few rounds
give me that with a little bit of
gravitas what one line and I'm being
directed okay I told you I would I told
you that I would calls read my way out
of any chance of replacing Robert Downey
jr. your job is safe well that was one
heck of a good time so what superhero
actors would you want to recast with
other superhero actors let us know in
the comments section below and tell us
why thanks again to Eminem for
sponsoring today's episode I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick's hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
[Music]